llegamos aquí
[Música]
que quiere ser cuando seas niño
si la pregunta está bien formulada la
mayoría de las respuestas que me dan
ante esta pregunta es ser libre y ser
feliz
déjame decirte que ese niño libre y
feliz hoy está aquí y siempre ha vivido
en ti
así que vuelve a conectarte con ese niño
y te vas a conectar con tu creatividad
qué es esto
y el gesto
si solo viste una caja quiero invitarte
a que recuerdes esa tremenda imaginación
que tenías cuando eras niño cuando la
falta de complejos y prejuicios que
hacía crear sin miedo ni límites
entonces esto se convertía en una casa
se convertía en una nave espacial se
convertía en un carro de carreras el
mejor a medida que fuiste creciendo se
fueron imponiendo creencias normas
reglas y así poco a poco fueron apagando
tu creatividad les voy a poner rápido y
rápidamente un ejemplo la mamá de
marquito estaba preparándolo para una
fiesta lo peinó le arregló la ropa y le
dijo ahora ve hijo diviértete y pórtate
bien a lo que el niño contestó por favor
mamá antes de irme decídete por una de
las dos
evidentemente el niño se dio cuenta de
una gran contradicción diviértete y
pórtate bien algo que quizás la madre no
pudo darse cuenta yo soy un pregunto me
encanta hacer preguntas hacer preguntas
me permite agitar e inquietar mentes por
eso tengo otra pregunta para ti
cuál es el sentido de la vida
para mí la vida no tiene sentido la vida
es una oportunidad para crear un sentido
entonces voy a cambiar la pregunta como
creo el sentido de mi vida
el sentido de la vida no se descubre y
necesita hay conseguir el sentido de la
vida o buscándolo en cualquier otra
parte el sentido de la vida hay que
crearla
el sentido de la vida tenemos que
crearlo la vida no está pre fabricada
tenemos la vida
y obtenemos de la vida lo que le ponemos
así que vamos a ponerle música vamos a
ponerle vida vamos a ponerle música
ritmo poesía sabor aromas
vamos a ser creativos
quiero invitarte a que seas creativo y
cuando digo que seas creativo no te
estoy diciendo que va a ser un gran
poeta o un gran pintor cuando te digo
que seas creativo
quiero decirte que dejes que tu vida sea
un gran poema deja que tu vida sea una
gran obra de arte por eso hoy quiero
invitarte a recuperar esa inocencia de
la niñez para ponerla a jugar en favor
de la creatividad hoy quiero invitarte a
ser aprendiz creativo y qué significa
ser aprendiz creativo ser aprendiz
creativo significa vivir preparado para
equivocarte sin miedos vivir preparado
para explorar para divertirte para jugar
para cuestionarlo todo para romper
esquemas para experimentar para
arriesgar para crear para fluir sin
límites para mantener despierta la
imaginación y potenciar la creatividad
día a día quiero invitarlos a que se
pongan de pie un momento por favor
quiero invitar quiero invitarte a ser un
aprendiz creativo porque por el
contrario un experto vive encerrado en
su propio hijo en su propio ego la mente
un experto es algo así como una caja
cerrada no entra nada nuevo y tampoco
sale nada y quedan allí sin espacio para
desaprender y los invite a ponerse de
pie para desaprender quizás una de las
mayores informaciones que se han
difundido en cuanto a la creatividad y
el cerebro que dice que la creatividad
solo depende del hemisferio derecho así
que vamos a hacer un pequeño ejercicio
para conectar nuestros hemisferios
cerebrales y darnos cuenta que la
creatividad depende de la intensidad de
las conexiones que se generen en nuestro
hemisferio lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
algo que yo creé y se llama el baile de
los hemisferios y tiene un poco de baile
y comenzamos así
luego hacemos un cambio bien aplaudimos
si aquí luego otra vez lo dimos y ahora
aquí y ahora cambiamos
muy bien y ahora más rápido 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 cambiamos bien muy bien por tomen
asiento muchas gracias
acabamos de generar conexiones entre
nuestras neuronas entre ambos
hemisferios fíjense se están riendo
dejaron de ser su estado tenemos cambio
al que estaba que tenían hace unos
segundos atrás
acabamos de incrementar los niveles de
dopamina una sustancia encargada de
permitir la la transmisión de
información entre las neuronas y está
relacionada con las funciones de la
creatividad la perspectiva y todas esas
actividades que nos hacen sentir bien y
nos hacen sentir feliz y ya que
conectamos nuestros hemisferios y
tenemos ese nivel de dopamina adecuado
ahora les voy a revelar cuatro cosas de
muchas que pueden hacer
a convertirse en un aprendiz creativa
la primera es
por acá
tienen un diario creativo no importa si
es un cuaderno una agenda un conjunto de
hojas en tu propio teléfono lo
importante es que las ideas que se
pasean por tu mente puedas escribirlas
aquí yo en mi diario aterrizó todas mis
ideas mis observaciones dibujos frases
aquí es donde comienzan a hacerse
realidad por eso es que te invito a que
tú tengas tu propio diario
luego de tener nuestro diario tenemos
que potenciar nuestra imaginación mejor
dicho tenemos que despertar esa
imaginación porque la imaginación es
algo que todos podemos hacer pero muy
poco hacemos entonces para estimular la
imaginación traje un gran amigo mío ya
puede salir a saludar dejarlos dejar los
nervios
saluda hola a todos
preséntate y tu nombre hola a todos soy
conoce si con oso conejo oso bueno me
gusta el chocolate y soy de este color
porque como mucha zanahoria además me
gusta mucho él ya conoce ya un aplauso
para conocer por favor y allá gracias
conoces que después la confianza
fíjense si quieres estimular tu
imaginación
tienes que animar y darle vida a objetos
inanimados animal o cada vez que un
amigo me dice mira el carro nuevo que me
compré mira el celular que me compré lo
primero que vamos preguntarle cómo se
llama
les vuelvo a preguntar a los vuelvo a
invitar recuerda nuevamente cuando eras
niño a cuantos objetos te diste vídeos
cuantas historias creaste
bueno qué más tengo por acá
si es esta
mi capa de superhéroe
esta es mi capa de superhéroe que me
permite volar al infinito hoy más allá
también puede ser mí
alfombra mágica oye sobre el té rojo luz
es mejor y me monto para ir a conquistar
una linda princesa
r
[Música]
en qué momento esto pasó a ser una
simple toalla
en qué momento dejaste imaginar que eras
un superhéroe
en qué momento tuviste miedo a volar
nuevamente ninguna alfombra mágica
miedos miedos algo que nos paraliza
tenemos miedo al qué dirán a las
críticas a lo que digan nuestros padres
nuestros amigos miedo a sí estoy muy
joven para empezar si estoy muy viejo
para empezar miedos miedos y más
hay un miedo más grande es el miedo a
equivocarse y si no estás preparado para
equivocarte nunca vas a crear nada
original extraordinario así que te
invito a que en lugar de
ponerte molesto por cometer un error
celebra lo celebra el error aliméntate
el error el error es símil es sinónimo
de valentía de que te estás atreviendo
sí
si no te atreves nunca vas a saber todo
lo que podías lograr así que dejemos los
miedos a un lado y llévate a esta
pregunta que harías de diferente manera
si no tuvieras miedo a cometer errores
preguntas preguntas y más preguntas las
preguntas nos estimulan la imaginación y
nos permiten abordar las situaciones que
se nos presentan día a día de una manera
diferente
generalmente cuando en las escuelas no
se valora la habilidad de hacer
preguntas en lugar de eso lo que más se
valora es la habilidad para tener la
respuesta
es la respuesta del profesor de la
persona que escribió el libro o de la
persona de autoridad y no se fomenta esa
capacidad para preguntar preguntar y
preguntar qué es la especialidad de los
niños y la gran habilidad de todo
aprendiz
entonces quiero invitarte a preguntar a
que no dejes de hacerlo
mantén esa curiosidad siempre viva
entonces tenemos nuestro diario creativo
imaginamos
luego soltamos nuestros miedos
preguntamos preguntamos y no paramos de
preguntar
arriésgate experimenta
quiere en ti
y cree
hoy estoy aquí en té de c's junto a
ustedes celebrando mi cumpleaños y estoy
celebrando mi cumpleaños haciendo lo que
más me apasiona y poniéndole sentido a
mi vida así que hoy quiero yo
obsequiarte dos cosas la primera es esta
caja
ya casi está vacía
y tú puedes decidir lo que quieren hacer
con ellas
tú puedes decidir si quieres meterte acá
a vivir como un experto
si la tomas
y jugar con ella y convertirla en las
miles de posibilidades o volaría un niño
o como lo haría un aprendiz creativa
el otro obsequio que tengo para ti
bien en este avión de papel
y es un poema de pablo neruda
y se titula
al pie desde su niño y dice sí
el pie del niño aún no sabe que es pie y
quiere ser mariposa o manzana pero luego
los videos y las piedras las calles las
escaleras y los caminos de la tierra
dura van enseñando al pie que no puede
volar que no puede ser fruto redondo en
una rama el pie del niño entonces fue
derrotado cayó en la batalla fue
prisionero condenado a vivir en un
zapato
poco a poco sin luz fue conociendo al
mundo a su manera sin conocer al otro
piel encerrado explorando la vida como
un 7 pero este ciego anduvo sin tregua
sin parar hora tras hora el pie y el
otro pie ahora de hombre o de mujer
arriba abajo por los campos las minas
los almacenes y los ministerios atrás
afuera adentro adelante este pie trabajo
con su zapato apenas tuvo tiempo de
estar desnudo en el amor o el sueño
camino caminaron hasta que el hombre
entero
y entonces a la tierra abajo y no supo
nada porque allí todo y todo estaba
oscuro no supo que había dejado de ser
piel si lo enterraban para que volaran o
para que pudiera
muchas gracias
[Música]
el tiempo